lentejuelas y disfraces todos los
ingredientes de las bandas callejeras
del carnaval de Río están aquí y para el
bloque de barbas hay algo extra su
mensaje político
los brasileños sufren mucho por la
política así que qué mejor que
divertirse con ella reírse de ella en
lugar de llorarla
este bloque es uno de los más
tradicionales de río
Cricket Rodríguez es la hija del
fundador que fue prisionero de la
dictadura militar rentaba un restaurante
donde se reunían intelectuales de la
resistencia
el barba será un restaurante político a
principios de los 80 todavía había
carteles en las paredes del restaurante
que decían que estaba prohibido tocar
Samba y este restaurante promovía La
música y la cultura había exposiciones
círculos de poesía teatro y se debatía
mucho Sobre política
detrás el bloque de barba se fundó hace
38 años tomando su nombre el restaurante
las canciones de samba compuestas por el
grupo son siempre sátiras políticas y
este año el expresidente Jair bolsillo
está en el centro de atención
[Música]
Este es el primer Carnaval desde que
dejó el cargo
dijo que él era un macho viril que nunca
fracasaba pero fracasó perdió las
elecciones Así que hemos aprovechado
para burlarnos de él fue muy divertido
el macho viril perdió
[Música]
después de un intento de golpe de estado
a principios de enero en Brasilia y a
pesar de la crisis económica los
brasileños quieren aprovechar al máximo
esta semana de fiesta